hemos visto que las ideas de una
molécula depende de la estabilidad de la
base conjugada en este vídeo vamos a ver
cómo es que la base conjugada se
estabiliza a través de un concepto de
inducción así que aquí tenemos tres
ácidos carboxílicos ok vamos a empezar
con el ácido carboxílicos que está en la
izquierda que es el ácido acético verdad
este es el ácido que más viene este es
el protón ácido verdad y tiene un valor
pk aproximadamente de 4.76 por otro lado
tenemos el ácido cloro acético y aquí
tenemos nuestro protón ácido y tiene un
valor p cada de 2.85 y finalmente
tenemos el ácido de color acético verdad
y este sería nuestro protón relevante y
tiene un pecado de 1.48 entonces como
puedes ver la tendencia es que si nos
movemos hacia la derecha
movemos hacia la derecha aumenta la
acidez verdad esta es la tendencia en
este en estos tres ejemplos ahora esto
vamos a tratar de explicarlo a partir de
sus bases con jugadas verdad tendremos
esta base con jugada aquí el oxígeno
obtiene una carga formal negativa
en este caso tendremos nuevamente este
oxígeno con el enlace doble un oxígeno
con carga
formal negativa y unido a nuestro cloro
a través de esta cadena verdad y
finalmente tendremos este bueno déjenme
empezar con el oxígeno
aquí tenemos este oxígeno enlace doble
un oxígeno con carga formal negativa ok
y esta cadena que conecta a estos dos
cloro entonces ahí lo tienen aquí no
vamos a estar dibujando los pares
solitarios de electrones en este vídeo
porque pienso que eso podría confundir
el punto que quiero hacer así que vamos
a si gustan pueden ver vídeos anteriores
para ver dónde es que esos electrones
solitarios se encuentran verdad así que
con esto aquí tenemos estas bases con
jugadas con una carga formal negativa y
sabemos que esa carga negativa se puede
deslocalizar verdad se puede
deslocalizar por ejemplo en este caso
en esta zona verdad sabemos que eso
depende de la cantidad de estructuras
resonantes que podemos encontrar verdad
esto se puede deslocalizar en esta zona
entonces esta característica es la que
le permite al ácido acético pues es
relativamente ácido verdad ahora si nos
fijamos en la base conjugada del ácido
clorogénico digamos vamos vamos a
dibujar bueno ya tenemos aquí la base
conjugada entonces la única diferencia
que tenemos es la presencia de esta
molécula o más perdón de este cloro en
la molécula verdad así que nuevamente
podríamos pensar sobre la estructura de
resonancia para esta base conjugada que
justamente es lo que nos permite tener
estos electrones localizados en esta
porción de la molécula verdad que es lo
que le da estabilidad a esta base
conjugada sin embargo como tenemos la
presencia de este átomo electro negativo
de este cloro de aquí
este cloro es más electro negativo que
el carbono verdad
este cloro en este cloro de aquí es más
electro negativo que el carbono del cual
está unido así que va a jalar estos dos
electrones que se encuentran en el
enlace los va a jalar más cerca de él
así que si a este efecto
se le conoce como el efecto inductivo ok
así que así que esos dos esos electrones
son jalados más cerca digamos al átomo
electro negativo y por lo tanto esos
electrones son jalados aparte de este
carbono verdad este carbono de aquí
haciendo que ese carbono sea
parcialmente positivo y entonces este
cloro en el electro negativo decimos que
es removedor de electrones y puede
remover alguna
digamos cierta densidad de electrones
afuera de este carbono y por lo tanto
podría también digamos jalar cierta
carga negativa de esta porción de la
molécula verdad así que también podemos
deslocalizar esa carga negativa en esta
porción verdad en esta porción de la
molécula también debido a la presencia
del electrón que es
digamos quitando estos electrones verdad
eso eso estabiliza la base con jugada
todavía más y como tenemos una base con
jugada más estable eso nos permite o le
permite al ácido cloro acético ser más
ácido que el ácido acético así que ésta
esta propiedad de jalar el de densidad
de electrones es lo que llamamos
inducción así que este efecto inductivo
disminuye el valor de cada para el ácido
cloro acético vamos a esta última a este
último ejemplo
en este último ejemplo no solo tenemos
esta propiedad de la estructura
resonante sino que tenemos digamos dos
grupos que atraen electrones verdad
cierta definida de electrones entonces
eso va a hacer que sea todavía más
estable esta base conjugada vamos a
tener esta presencia de dos átomos o
electrón negativos y cada uno tiene un
efecto inductivo y cada uno está
trayendo cierta densidad de electrones y
por lo tanto esta está esta carga
negativa verdad así que esta carga
negativa se puede dispersar todavía más
en esta base conjugada y esta base
conjugada es la más estable debido al
hecho que tiene más electrones perdón
tiene más átomos que atraen electrones
en esta molécula y como es la máx la más
estable de las tres eso significa que el
ácido ciclo acético es el más ácido y
podemos ver esto reflejado en los
valores pk así que este efecto inductivo
resulta ser también dependiente de la
distancia mientras más
cerca estemos de átomos electro
negativos
mientras más cerca están los átomos
electro negativos de la carga negativa
de tu base con jugada más efecto va a
tener así que podemos ver esto reflejado
en los siguientes ejemplos vamos vamos a
ver estos ejemplos ahí tienen estos dos
ácidos muy bien
el primero es el ácido 3 cloro butano y
ccoo mientras que el segundo es el ácido
2 cloro butano vamos a ver como la
posición del cloro y la distancia a
digamos a la carga negativa es
importante aquí podemos ver la
diferencia de los valores de cada verdad
en realidad la única diferencia es la
ubicación del átomo electro negativo así
que vamos vamos a ver
así que en el primer caso el cloro se
encuentra en el carbono vamos vamos a
contar de aquí
este es el 1 el 2 el 3 este cloro se
encuentra en el carbono 3 mientras que
en el segundo caso se encuentra en el
carbono 2 y nuevamente tenemos un efecto
inductivo y está este efecto es
dependiente de la distancia lo cual
significa que si perdemos este protón
por ejemplo si perdemos este protón y
nos quedamos con una carga negativa de
-1 este hecho de que el cloro esté
relativamente más cerca en este caso
aquí también tendremos una carga
negativa en este caso el hecho de que
esté más más cerca va a tener un efecto
mayor cuando estabiliza la base
conjugada que el ejemplo de la izquierda
verdad el cloro podría estar mucho más
allá de la carga y eso hace que sea más
inestable
la molécula así que el efecto inductivo
también es dependiente de la distancia
mientras más cerca esté el átomo
electrón negativo
el grupo digamos que atrae electrones el
mayor va a ser el efecto que tiene sobre
el pk vamos a ver más ejemplos
vamos a ver estos tres ácidos aquí
tenemos el ácido propano y ccoo ha sido
pro y genoy co perdón y ácido propinó y
co verdad y eso depende de los enlaces
que tenemos en este caso el primero este
es el digamos el protón ácido y tiene un
pecado de 4.87 este sería nuestro protón
importante y éste tiene un pecado de
4.25 y éste también sería el importante
y tiene un este un pecado de 1.84
nuevamente si si si te das cuenta esto
lleva una tendencia hacia la derecha de
aumentar la acidez aunque entonces aquí
aquí vamos a tratar de hacerlos las
bases con jugadas tenemos
por ejemplo este de aquí aquí sería la
carga negativa y tenemos esta cadena
verdad en este caso tenemos nuevamente
este esta misma estructura pero aquí
tenemos un enlace doble y finalmente es
la misma estructura para el tercer ácido
solo que tenemos un enlace triple verdad
tenemos este enlace triple
ahora el ácido propiónico es el más
ácido de estos tres y lo podemos
explicar en términos de la estabilidad
de las bases con jugadas simplemente a
partir de estos enlaces si nos fijamos
en el de la izquierda tenemos dos
carbonos con hibridación sp3 verdad en
este caso tenemos dos carbonos con
hibridación sp2 mientras que en este
último tenemos dos carbonos con
hibridación s&p verdad para este triple
enlace de aquí ahora resulta ser que los
carbonos con hibridación esp son más
electro negativos que los que tienen
hibridación sp2 y nuevamente los que
tienen hibridación sp2 son más electro
negativos que los con los que tienen
hibridación sp3 así que hay muchas
muchas formas de calcular la electro
negatividad y todas esas formas ya las
hemos hecho verdad son las formas en que
en qué
o más bien en de todas las formas que se
conocen todas coinciden en esta
tendencia general así que la hibridación
esp de los carbonos es la más electro
negativa y por lo tanto podríamos pensar
en ellos como si fueran grupos que
atraen electrones así que tenemos un
efecto inductivo e iu que afecta la
estabilidad de la base de la base
conjugada así que si los carbonos tienen
hibridación sp
ok son los más electro negativos y van a
traer cierta densidad de electrones de
esta forma así que nuevamente podrías
pensar a las bases con jugadas como que
tienen carga y carga deslocalizada
verdad mientras que tienen la carga de
es localizada en esta zona
digamos por por la por las estructuras
las estructuras resonantes debido a esta
electro negatividad que tienen estos
grupos se puede también digamos
extrapolar a esta porción de la molécula
y nuevamente tenemos este efecto de
deslocalización
que podríamos por ejemplo representarlo
con unas flechitas aquí verdad vamos a
ponerlo de esta forma vamos a ponerlo de
esta forma esto es que este grupo atrae
cierta densidad de electrones lo mismo
pudimos haber hecho acá arriba verdad
este cloro tiene la tendencia de atraer
electrones hacia él verdad lo mismo en
este caso y lo mismo en el caso anterior
verdad este hacia acá
hacia acá verdad pero bueno vamos a
continuar nuestros ejemplos vamos a ver
unos últimos dos ahí lo tienen y hemos
estado hablando de grupos que atraen
electrones y en este último ejemplo
vamos a ver uno en donde en realidad o
bueno podríamos pensarlo como que están
cediendo electrones están donando los y
que por supuesto tendría un efecto
contrario verdad sobre la base con
jugada así que tenemos dos ácidos
carboxílicos más y resulta hacer que el
ácido acético este de aquí que ya hemos
estado trabajando mucho es más ácido que
esta molécula de la izquierda verdad
nuevamente vamos a ver esto a través de
las bases con jugadas vamos a dibujarlo
tenemos nuestra base con jugada del
ácido acético aquí lo tenemos ya lo
hemos pintado muchas veces tenemos el
oxígeno con carga negativa y el grupo
metilo
aquí en este caso tendríamos la misma
estructura sólo que este oxígeno lleva
una carga formal negativa y copiamos
este grupo tribu til verdad así que
cuando pensamos en los grupos alquiló
que en este caso sería el grupo metilo y
este término verdad
en ese caso resulta ser que los grupos
al kilo son donadores de electrones
y mientras más sustituidos sean los
grupos al kilo digamos más electrones
van a donar verdad van a ser más
donadores de electrones así que si nos
fijamos en el de la izquierda este es un
grupo alquiló muy sustituido verdad este
grupo tribu tilos de aquí es es más o
menos donador de electrones así que
podríamos pensar que está cediendo ésta
está siguiendo una cierta carga negativa
verdad verdad aunque sea muy pequeña es
una carga negativa y como las cargas
similares se repelen esto es la carga
negativa de este lado simplemente se
repele del lado de la izquierda verdad y
eso desestabiliza nuestra base con
jugada con jugada y como se
desestabiliza la base con jugada por
supuesto vamos a disminuir la acidez de
esta molécula de aquí verdad y cuando
estudiamos el este el lado derecho
podríamos ver que simplemente tenemos un
grupo metilo de este lado que no está
tan sustituido digamos como el término
así que no va a donar tantos electrones
y como no dona tantos electrones no va
de esas veces perdón desestabilizar
tanto a la base con jugada y por lo
tanto va a hacer que nuestro ejemplo de
la derecha que es el ácido acético sean
más
ha sido verdad y esa es la razón por la
cual aumenta la acidez de la molécula
así que en resumen podríamos pensar a
los grupos al kilo podríamos pensar a
los grupos al kilo como si fueran un
poco digamos donadores de electrones y
esto por supuesto tendrá un efecto sobre
el valor pk